okay so my first stop is going to be to
our customer and partner and sponsor
business I've been to a lot of tech
conferences in my time and some of my
favorite conversations are the
conversations who can actually use our
products not only that it's a really
really cool swag at their boobs so
that's always a perfect and also there's
some really cool like experiences the
only way I can Define it is an
experience let me just show you behind
me there is a Wizard of Oz theme Booth I
think we will meet Dorothy real quick
wow look at this this is incredible
Dorothy
Dorothy are there clouds Over the
Rainbow
oh my gosh this is the coolest thing I
have ever seen at a conference look at
your ruby slippers my shoes
matches that you can't see online
[Music]